peu
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
voici venir ce qu'on nomme les fidèles
mais gardien du palais
ces présents
the et qui a choisi xerxès veiller sur
sa terre en son absence
[Musique]
quand notre roi reviendra-t-il et notre
armée
assez d'or
mon coeur s'agiter train par un
pressentiment funeste
elle est parti si loin la puissance de
l'asie
force m'est de l'asie tout entière
hautcoeur anxieux appelle un porteur de
nouvelles mais aucun message et
mul courrier à cheval
est encore arrivée dans la capitale
tous
[Musique]
tous ont quitté nos villes de suse des
platanes et des vieux remparts de kiss
ya ils sont partis sur leurs chevaux sur
les navires de guerre dans le
piétinement sans fin des soldats ils
sont partis les chefs des perses
mais être d'une immense armée à mr est
certes à fresnay ce méga ma thèse c'est
un stade ps artem barrès dressé sur son
cheval de guerre màj stress et ils
maillot ce brave avec son arc
infaillible ouah obéissant tous aux rois
[Musique]
d'autres sont accourus des 13 communes
non
auditionné
[Musique]
m
les bateliers des spa avec leur bar une
petite eu du nombre hamlet terry
ne serait ce pas
m
ensuite la foule des lydien raffinés m
eras de leur empire et sadler cité la
ville dort les envoie au combat sur leur
char et charles quatre des six chevaux
chacun sur l'ebit
moi
[Musique]
venez d'arriver need more sacré votre
rêve aussi de mettre au crec l'échelle
des esclaves et voici que demain milone
capitale de l'or jaillissent les hommes
et les dates en marenger carlier arraché
sur deux le rap
[Musique]
ainsi julos enfin des profondeurs de
l'asie ces peuples ont pris les armes à
feu plaimont soumis aux ordres du
caurroy
aux citrons mieux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette éloigner la fleur des galets père
pleure terre d'asie toi qui les nourrit
pleure sur
et consume toit de regrets
mais bon
leurs mères et les femmes confient les
jours et troubles et d'avoir trop
longtemps attendu
elle a dû débarquer l'armée royale
l'armée de la dévastation et les
tendresses oui pour toucher le continent
d'en face pour franchir le détroit et
l'a jetée sur l'eau la chaîne d'un pont
de navire comme un jour au coût de la
mer il te faudra fois au berger de
l'asie pour conduit en europe le
troupeau sans nombre des soldats la
route de la mer et la route de la terre
aux xerxès fils de la pluie d'or morte
elle aussi grand que les dieux tuer le
dragon sanguinaire le dragon regarde
flammes aux mille bras aux mille voile
tuer la terre avec son arc aveugle
tu es là que la lance qui pourrait par
et le passage au cours de ce fleuve
humain
quel geek a jamais contenu invincible à
son de l'année ainsi déferlante et du ps
sans résistance
là
pas
m
[Musique]
à
mais quand un dieu veut nous tromper qui
pourrait déjouer sarrus quel animal
prise au piège sont répondirent hors des
filets ainsi l'homme tombé dans la
trappe de l'erreur ne peut s'en évader
ni prendre la fuite ou le destin nous a
t-il comment des perses de faire la
guerre ou sur terre ou pour les citer
mais voilà nous avons voulu tourner nos
regards vers la mer la mer fouetter
devant blanche des cubes est lancé sur
la route océane de fragile vaisseaux
chargés de nos soldats
[Musique]
la cheville droite sur l'avenue bears
attendrons nous que creed en sus la
capitale sans hommes
[Musique]
oh
attin jaillir aussi ce cri funèbre des
remparts de titia eaux et de la gorge de
nos femmes mettant leurs robes en
lambeaux
[Musique]
tout un peuple de cavaliers tout un
peuple de fantassins a disparu comme un
essaim d'abeilles derrière le chef de la
[Musique]
resté seul
le ray dans votre ministère pleurer
l'absence de vos hommes partys avec
votre
mais voici qu'apparaît la mère du grand
roi notre reine et sa vue ébloui comme
un regard des lieux à genoux douce pour
te saluer comme il convient souveraine
absolue des femmes de perse vénérable
mère de xerxès femme de dariaus femme
d'un dieu mère de dieu peut être si
seulement
oui si seulement la fortune des armes ne
s'est pas retourné contre nous déchirée
par la même angoisse
je n'ai pu rester davantage entre les
murs tort du palais j'ai quitté la
chambre où j'ai si longtemps partagé la
couche de dario pour venir mes amis les
plus fidèles soutiens du trône ou
demander un conseil par le maîtresse de
notre terre nous sommes prêts à
t'écouter dispose de notre sagesse
chaque nuit depuis que mon fils a lancé
son armée à l'assaut de la grèce mon
sommeil est peuplé de rêves mais le plus
clair de tous est aussi le dernier que
je fis écoute j'ai vu surgir deux femmes
devant moi infiniment plus grande et
plus belle que toute femme d'aujourd'hui
l'une portait la robe père l'autre la
tunique d'oriel elle était de même sens
mais leur patrie c'était diverses
la première habitait la grèce l'autre la
terre barbare elles se prennent de
querelles mais monfils survient à son
tour les saisies les appels à son char
et leur paso coup les harnais une des
femmes emparé fier et prête sa bouche
aux morts mais l'autre résiste se cabre
déchire son harnais et brisant deux le
joug faisant tomber mon fils dario
lui se penchent prêt à le consoler mais
xerxès à sa vue déchire tous ses
vêtements
c'est là que mon rêve a pris fin à peine
réveillé je les tremper mes mains dans
une eau pure est porté à l'hôtel de nos
dieux protecteurs l'offrande d'un repas
rituel vers le soleil levant voler un
aigle et soudain images terribles qui
m'arrêtera sur place épouvanté du plus
profond du ciel je vis fondera faut
qu'on lègue l'agrippé par la tête
aveugle et déchiqueté est mort en un
instant censé être défendu nous nous
voulons au maire ni effrayer davantage
ne rassurait tout à fait le sens de ces
présages funestes
mais au dieu seul on n'appartient ni su
conjurer demandeur ans cliente côté
songe d'été visions ne prennent jamais
corps pas rien lors de rennes pour toi
pour tous les tiers et pour notre pays
le dard tout dépendra d'animation sur la
terre pour les morts et puisque tu l'as
vue aurait tué invoquera dario ce qu'ils
n'envoient plus à la lumière du jour
que des présage favorable et qu'il
retienne le malheur dans l'obscurité de
la terre tu voulais deux mois des
conseils
voilà ce que m'inspire mon coeur je vais
les suivre aussi tôt mais avant de
rentrer au palais une dernière question
mes amis en quel point de la terre dit
on que se trouve athènes très loin vers
l'occident où tu vois se coucher le
tout-puissant soleil et pourquoi mon
fils veut dire à tout prix se rendre
maître de cette ville pour être maître
de tous les grecs ont-ils port armes
comme nous l'arc à la flèche non
marraine l'épée et le bouclier les grecs
combattent corps à corps quelle est leur
chef
comment appelle-t-on leurs maîtres ils
n'en n'ont pas les grecs ne sont
esclaves ni sujet de personnes et tu
crois qu'il pourrait repousser nos
soldats je sais qu'ils ont défait
l'armée de dario ce que tes paroles font
de mal à une mère angoissée
bientôt tu sauras tout je vois venir un
message et c'est un des nôtres
il court comme pour les perses par lui
nous connaîtrons douce ouamer la vérité
au site et de l'asie entière aux perses
ma patrie gardienne de présence en
nombre
il a suffi d'un coup pour anéantir ta
fortune faucher piétiner la fleur de thé
enfants malheur terrible plus triste
encore pour moi qui en suis le premier
message et mais mon destin m'ordonne de
vous présenter le désastre aux perses
dans toute son étendue
l'armée l'armée barbare tout entière a
péri
ma
g
[Musique]
mon
de ceux qui sont partis aucun n'a
survécu
et moi même c'est par miracle que je
revoie la lumière du pays natal
[Musique]
avant
mon
hélas ne doutez pas de mes paroles j'ai
tout vu de mes propres yeux
[Musique]
pourquoi tout rien l'arc était sans
pouvoir nos soldats nos marins cerné par
les navires grecs sont morts jusqu'aux
derniers no more couvre les côtes de
l'île de salamine la plage en est jonché
et chaque jour la mère y dépose d'autres
corps
[Musique]
oh
coc
[Musique]
les gens sont verts vous à cri de
désespoir
au menu
[Musique]
à
malamine
m
[Musique]
martin barrette chef de dix mille
cavaliers s'est noyé au large de
salamine est les rochers du cap silène
déchire ce qui reste de vie
marthe eragon passe de bactriane échoués
sur la grève de l'île mentana qu'est-ce
qui commandait à 1000 soldats précipité
du haut de son navire sous le choc d'un
javelot mans-lille as you are sames
argué steiss flottant autour de l'île
des colombes leur feront vainq ueur
temps sans trêve le rivage
marc eu aussi les chefs l'égyptien à des
us arceus par nikos tombé du même
vaisseau mamata l'os de crise m de dix
mille hommes
et son sang répandu dans la mer 1 2 pour
sa barbe mort arabos le mage est apte à
metz de bactriane chef de 30 mille
cavaliers noirs mo ram estrie c'est en
fils très us l'infatigable are you marc
dos et c'est à metz
mokhtar ibis commandant 5 x 50 cas l'air
et sienne esi souverain de cilicie tombé
lui aussi en héros
voilà les noms dont j'ai gardé le
souvenir
mais tant d'autres chefs ont péri il me
semble n'avoir citer personne
écrasés sous le poids d'un tel désastre
je n'ai pu prendre la parole me poser la
moindre question
mais il est temps de se ressaisir et de
faire face aux malheurs qu'il plaît au
dieu de nous envoyer par le don messager
fait nous le récit de notre infortune et
quelques douleurs qu'il tend coûte
n'épargne aucun détail xerxès lui est
vivant il voit la lumière du jour la
lumière aussi est revenu en moi
éclatante le jour à chasser la nuit
noire messager combien de vaisseau
possédait-il ces grecs pour avoir eu
l'audace de nous attaquer et prendre
l'initiative d'un combat naval si le
nombre seuls en avait décidé la victoire
aujourd'hui appartiendrait aux barbares
la flotte grecque ce composé d'environ
300 triaire celle de xerxès j'en suis
témoin n'en comprenais pas moins de 1100
comptait 216 bâtiment rapide
tel était le rapport des forces
etions-nous défavorisés la défaite de
notre armée il faut qu'un dieu l'ait
voulu en mettant tout le poids de la
chance du côté de nos ennemis les dieu
protège la cité de la déesse athéna
la ville d'athènes est donc encore
intacte
sauvé par le rempart inébranlable de ses
hommes dis moi maintenant qui donna le
signal du combat les grecs ou bien
monfils trop confiants dans la
supériorité de ses forces tout notre
malo marraine est née de la haine d'un
dieu d'un génie inconnu et coûte cher
c'est ce avait établi son camp sous les
murs mêmes d'athènes que ses habitants
avaient abandonné pour se réfugier dans
l'île de salamine sous la protection de
l'armée de la flotte grecque
un homme venue secrètement de chez les
athéniens s'est présenté à ton fils et
lui a dit
les grecs ont assez attendu
ils ont décidé de fuir salamine ce soir
même à la faveur des ténèbres leur
navire lèveront l'ancré et se
disperseront dans la nuit vous hershey
ce lait coûte 100 soupçonnés dans cette
nouvelle la russe d'un grec un piège
tendu par les dieux il rassemble ses
commandants et leur déclare quand les
rayons du soleil auront cessé de
chauffer la terre et quand les ombres de
la nuit auront envahi le ciel vous
déploierez sur trois rangs la plus
grande partie de vos navires pour
bloquer tout passage à la flotte des
grecs le reste de vos vaisseaux voulant
vers est cerné salamine et s'il y
échappe tout massacre c'est vous tous
qui aurait la tête tranchée
ainsi parla le roi trop sûr de lui
s'il avait pu savoir quels lendemains
lui préparer les lieux
nos troupes dans un ordre parfait font
leurs derniers préparatifs vérifie
l'état des rames à la tombée de la nuit
les rameurs montrent d'abord suivi de
tous les combattants et tandis que les
cris d'encouragement se répondent un
banc à l'autre chaque navire va prendre
son poste de combat mais toute la nuit
s'écoule sans que la flotte des grecs
tentent le mouvement annoncé le jour se
lève c'est blanc chevaux galopent déjà
sur la surface de la terre
quand tout-à-coup éclate dans le silence
un formidable cris clameurs d'abord
confuse qui s'ordonne en un chant
solennelle l'hymne eu des grecs
le pays en est les rocs de salamine on
répercute les voi x l'écho quel désarroi
pour nos soldats bavard nous aurait-on
tromper
non ce n'est pas pour fuir que les grecs
entonné leur chant de guerre c'est pour
s'élancer contre nous et mettre à
l'unisson leur courage et les flammes
des trompettes s'allume de toutes parts
les rames bien rythmé frappe la mer et
s'en arrache pour la frapper à nouveau
la flotte grecque se déploie en ordre de
bataille son aile droite en avant et
l'on peut maintenant distinguer les
paroles de l'hymne allons fils de la
grèce libérons la patrie délivrons nos
enfants et nos femmes
rendons à nos dieux lares sautel leur
sépulture à nos ancêtres à l'ombre il
faut vaincre ou mourir
en réponse un bourdonnement confus court
tout le long de nos vaisseaux mais déjà
c'est le shark des étraves le bronze
fait sonner le bronze
le premier un bâtiment grec a défoncé la
proue d'une galère phénicienne et chaque
navire ennemi à cet exemple a visé l'un
des nôtres pour y planter son éperon les
premiers rangs de notre flotte résiste
d'abord aux chocs
mais il faut que la masse des navires se
précipite à son secours
qu'attendent ils hélas entassés dans la
passe trop étroites qui commande l'accès
de salamine paralysé il se blesse centre
de l'impact bronze et fracasse le
ramenant chevet très dans chacun d'eux
parvient à déboucher du chenal les grecs
à 10 contre 1 le cern l'écrasent le cool
et nos navires chavirer s'engloutissent
dans ce qui était la mère et qui n'est
plus maintenant qu'une épaisse couche
des pavés de cadavres sanglants des
morts rien que des morts surtout le
rivage de l'île des morts sur chaque
récif tandis que nos derniers navires
tour de leurs rames et se lance dans une
fuite éperdue les grecs cherche à la
surface de l'eau ce qui ne sont pas
encore noyé
et les assomme avec des morceaux de bois
débris du naufrage comme on achète des
tons des poissons à pêcher et jusqu'à
l'heure où s'ouvrent enfin le sombre de
la nuit la brise de mer d'un porte au
large que les cris des agonisants
quel est le nombre de nos morts si je
voulais les compter tous dix jours ne me
suffirait pas sage seulement oren que
jamais non jamais tant d'hommes n'ont
disparu dans l'espace d'un seul jour son
est fini de vous ambition espérances de
la perse foudroyé par la haine d'un dieu
et toi mon fils trop jaloux de la gloire
d'athènes n'avait lui pas assez les
innombrables mort de marathon tu es
parti pour les venger et c'est la ruine
de ton empire que tu ramènes pour but un
messager parle moi des navires qui n'ont
pas sombré vers où sont ils partis le
ctu moraine j'ignore où les a conduit le
vent qui favorisa leur fuite mais je
peux te parler du reste de l'armée
puisque j'ai partagé ces épreuves
la débâcle nous fait traverser d'abord
la béotie ou tant des nôtres sont morts
de soif auprès des sources que nous
avions nous-mêmes décès chez d'autres
tombe d'épuisement le long des routes de
fossiles et du pays des d'oriens nous
parvenons enfin au golf du mail hills et
nous désaltérant à l'eau fraîche du sper
chios mais nos peines recommence en
traversant la thessalie la patrie des
achéens plus de vivre ni d'eau les lors
la soif et la faim ne cesserons de nous
faire escorte
combien d'entre nous en sont morts avant
d'atteindre la macédoine a new dernier
survivant
il reste encore à traverser la trace
interminable chemin
enfin nous voici en asie continent natal
terre de nos foyers
combien sommes nous à te revoir une
poignée de misérables qui ne savons plus
que pleurer pleurer aussi perse pleurer
les fruits de notre terre notre jeunesse
exterminer divinité du mal sous quelle
terrible poids viens-tu d'écraser notre
race comme vous parliez clair aux rêves
de ma nuit apparition de l'aurore et
vous vieillard n'avait pas su les
déchiffrer pourtant je suivrai vos
premiers conseils je vais implorer les
dieux et porter une offrande aux
puissances souterraines
si vous voyez mon fils avant que je sois
de retour conforter le ne laissez pas
seuls empêcher le d'ajouter un malheur à
tout ce que nous venons de subir
[Musique]
ans
autre ce sera des dieux voit-on neige
anéanti l'armée des perses sa multitude
et son orgueil voile au site est voilée
de noir le deuil de s'user belle
bataille
les air cess les a perdus
[Musique]
au dessus ce soit le chagrin des maires
et des soeurs voile et déchiré des
vaillantes leurs hommes de leurs doigts
tremblants et les tremper
d'intarissables
[Musique]
au-dessus s'écoute les sanglots d'ever
écoute les pleurer la jeunesse et la
force de l'homme sait caresser la
douceur lui les raffinements du plaisir
à jamais disparu
en tant leur désespoir que rien n'a ps
[Musique]
c'est la vie entière qui gémit l'asie
vidé de tout son sens
tél
[Musique]
m
sur les zones noires
on sort
ma
en somme
[Musique]
à
aujourd'hui encore déchiré plante le
décor
[Musique]
dumora
à
[Musique]
chez eux
si l'erreur
géré par le centre of
[Musique]
et pas
jamais
voilà
[Musique]
e
m
mais pas
c'est pas
quel jeu
oh
[Musique]
à
m
[Musique]
c'est un
je n'ai pas fait ça
[Musique]
ça
vrai
[Applaudissements]
puissance du grand roi force triomphante
des perses la terre de salamine vous a
plu avec le sang de nos soldats
lançons notre cri jusqu'aux plus hauts
de seine
[Musique]
à
non ça la mine
allez
non
[Musique]
à
n'oubliez jamais aux femmes
désormais sans fils ni marie atteignent
monde y soit au nom bien des siècles
passeront avant que l'ordre et la loi
perses ne règne encore sur l'asie il se
dresse déjà les peuples agenouillé
arrachant leur bâillon et leurs chaînes
et la voix d'homme libre s'élève là où
tremblay des esclaves
puissance du grand roi force triomphante
de perse la terre de salamine vous a bu
avec le sang de nos soldats
amis vous le savez l'homme que le destin
favorise crois qu'il sera toujours
favorisé mais il ne cesse plus de
trembler celui qui a renversé la vague
du malheur aujourd'hui tout me troubler
mallard partout mes yeux croit voir les
signes de la colère divine
une rumeur obsédante pour donne à mes
oreilles terreur dont rien ne peut me
délivrer alors j'ai quitté le palais
j'ai fait offrande au père de mon fils
des libations qui apaise est mort pour
eux j'ai apporté le miel translucide et
le lait d'une vache qui n'a jamais porté
le joug mêlée à l'eau d'une fontaine
vierge pour eux les fruits de l'olivier
d'argent au feuillage mortels et des
fleurs entre la cfi de la terre fertile
et vous cependant mes amis
commencez votre incantations que vos
voix parcourant les demeures des morts
appel sans répit l'ombre de dario et la
fasse monter jusqu'à nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e
[Musique]
pour le maillot
homo
en
[Musique]
oh
nous verrons
[Musique]
on
hu
oh
ouais
allez on
[Musique]
oh
on
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui n'aurait pas laissé massacrer les
tons armée entière
argos inspiré par la gueule tu savais
bonne et des sandales
[Musique]
hu
en
[Musique]
la nuit
on va
bonjour
alors
[Musique]
barrios par 2 revient à rioz meurtre de
notre maître en temps de crise are you
revient
[Musique]
animaux
on
ça
[Musique]
ouais
votre voix ridel centre les fidèles
dernier témoin de ma jeunesse à votre
appel à vos cris de détresse la terre
s'est fendu est mort à vous j'ai su
fléchir les maître des enfers
mais il est court le délai qu'ils m'ont
accordée aussi aller moins vite
quel malheur nouveau appelé c'est mon
envie
pardonne moi seigneur j'ai peur de te
parler
j'ai peur rien qu'à voir la même terreur
contre x ce taux ne convient plus sigi
reparu devant vous c'est pour obéir à
vos plein et vous répondre le temps mais
mesurée par les donges peut tout
entendre
oublié le respect que vous deviez on
voit non signèrent la terreur m'a saisi
et glacée dans ma bouche les mots qui te
ferait du mal
si vous ne pouvez la dominer la crainte
que vous inspirez leroy et bien c'est
toi que je voudrais man up femmes
toi qui a si longtemps partagé mon lit
interrompt des sanglots et suites et
l'art et 10 mois toute la vérité aux
alliances les perses enviait avis plus
heureux que les plus heureux des mortels
tu as connu la féliciter des dieux aussi
longtemps que tu as vu le soleil et
maintenant nous envions d'être mort
avant d'avoir plongé tes yeux dans le
gouffre de nos malheurs tu n'auras pas
longtemps à m'écouter toute la vérité
l'ars tient en ces quelques mots de la
puissance des pertes
il ne reste plus rien qui l'a détruite
est ce la peste est ce la guerre civile
ce sont les grecs non loin de la cité
d'athènes
ils ont anéanti notre armée et qui
l'avait mené là bas dit veut lequel de
mes fils le plus fou de xerxès vie dans
l'asie sur son passage
le fou le malheureux desquels route at
elle choisi la terre et la mer à la fois
son armée s'avançait sur deux fronts
mais son infanterie comment at elle pu
franchir la mer par ces bateaux nous et
comme une chaîne sur l'ailé ce pont il a
eu cette audace enchaîné le crampes au
score il a osé un dieu a dû éteindre sa
raison impitoyable dieu jusqu'où l'atv
gary jusqu'au désastre final
aumale l'irréparable
au point d'avoir perdu un peuple entier
écoute les lamentations de suse ta
capitale vidée de tous et âme aux
prophéties qui nous disait la ruine de
la perse à quelle incroyable vitesse
vous êtes vous réalisez et wars pour les
accomplir tu as choisi mon propre fils
espérer que les dieux montrerait moins
de lattes
mais pourquoi devrait-il patienter plus
longtemps lorsque c'est un mortel qui
provoque sa propre perte
hélas la source de nos malheurs
c'est un des miens c'est mon fils
incrédule que c'est ce qu'ils apprennent
être folle crime éviter toute la
jeunesse entraver les laisse consacré
ligoté par des chefs d'escale les
divine qui passera fermé par a forgé le
faire un des trois ouvert par les dieux
pour donner à ses troupes une route sans
mesure certes c'est ce qu'elle maladie
rap et à raison avoir voulu toi un
mortel des pieds posés donne dieu de la
mer et maintenant j'en ai peur les
trésors que mon règne à donner à la
perse seront une proie facile pour ceux
qui les premiers voudront s'en emparer
certes au cours de ma vie j'ai commandé
bien désarmés et en rien des terres mais
j'ai toujours su avec l'aide du sort et
viterra la perse pareil désastre
exerçait sa négliger les conseils de son
père trop jeune c'est sa jeunesse seul
qu'il a préféré écouter mes nouveaux
dariaus tout puissant nous sommes prêts
at obéir fixe nous notre conduite
les perses sauront s'y tenir même avec
des guerriers 100 fois plus nombreux
même avec une arme et 100 fois plus
forte en attaque et jamais les grecs la
terre aussi combat pour eux la terre qui
te fait dire cela
elle a laissé mourir nos soldats par
milliers morts de faim de ceux qui sont
restés là bas sur le sol grec pas sain
ne reviendra qu'à dix soldats père se
serait encore en europe et vif au vivant
mais pour mourir d'une mort plus lente
et plus cruel prix de leur orgueil
insensé punition de leurs sacrilège
ils ont incendié les temples ils ont
saccagé les hôtels
ils sont renversés les statuts leur
châtiment ne fait que commencer
l'édifice de leurs souffrances nommé
qu'à ses fondations
mais il grandira jusqu'aux fêtes et
pendant trois générations des montagnes
de mort resteront dressée comme pour
dire aux vivants contempler ce qui vous
attend mortel qui voulaient des pieds
les immortels l'orgueil en mûrissant
fait germer le grain de l'ivraie
et c'est dans le sang et des larmes que
se fera la moisson garder les yeux
ouverts sur cette image
et quand xerxès sera de retour parmi
vous que chaque jour votre sagesse vie
répète au roi souviens-toi d'athènes et
de la cresse et toi même exerçaient ce
rentre dans ton palais revêt la plus
belle parure pour un dégoût devant de
ton fils
ces vêtements à lui ses robes aux
couleurs éclatantes ne sont plus sur son
corps que hay ont déchiré déchiré par sa
propre douleur calme ne parle lui tu es
la seule jeu c'est la seule au monde
qu'il supportera d'écouter l'heure est
venue je disparais dans l'ombre de la
terre
vieillard écouté mon dernier conseillait
même au plus profond de nos peines
chaque journée nous offre un peu de joie
laissez-la électret dans vos coeurs car
la mort abolie da jamais lusage de la
fortune
hélas que la vie était large et facile
dans nos cités quand le vieux roi
régnait sur notre terre le tout-puissant
barrios l'invincible dariaus barrios
égal aux dieux combien de villes combien
de province dariaus tu avais su
conquérir par sa seule volonté sans même
franchir nos frontières sans même
quitter ton palais toutes les villes du
pays traces de l'ailé ce pont et du
bosphore qui commandait les détroits et
la grappe de ces îles à la pointe de
l'asie l'espace mykonos chez naxos samos
la terre d olive qui haussent andros est
en hausse et les îles plus lointaines
jeté entre deux continents les menacent
le pays car l'île de ré du cnid et pas
fausser solace et toute l'île de chypre
et les villes ionienne de la côte d'asie
si riches réserves inépuisables degrés
mais aujourd'hui la fortune a tourné
contre nous et c'est nous qui courent
bon la tête
vaincus par les dieux et la mer
malheur à moi alors à la race des perses
frappé par un dieu naufrageurs en vous
voyant ici au vieillard de ma ville je
sens mes membres se briser m'abandonner
la force de mon corps pourquoi tu suces
m'avoir interdit de partager le sens de
mes guerriers au boulou dit dans la même
enseigne
tu fais des trucs assez du tuf et de la
force de lire ce que tu fais que tu fais
de drones américains s'est jeté au
centre et sacrifient aux enfers dafoe
fait de son armée as nous a tout pris
le dieu grec des combats les bleu marine
et les rivages ennemis il a foncé nos
soldats ou les acculer s'était chef de
guerre ce parent ta caisse sammis et de
tamas acteur apte à assumer la cob s'est
fait souffler sous giscard s achève sur
la table ils ne sont plus tombées devant
ça la vie
leurs corps meurtri parsèment les
rochers à ses yeux tu sais que tu fais
le ton à un gars qui fait de france par
exemple la gauche
[Musique]
à
heures à moi ils ont vu les plus ratés
l'abominable à peine 6 2
ap
ils gisent sur le sable agonisantes
saignant que tu fais que tu fais
à
[Musique]
et voilà
cruel
le mot
plus tout droit de la claire mon gars
et dans chacun des membres il ajouté
les châteaux mon armée
[Musique]
ils ont péri et chef de mon armée les
eaux perry et nous anéantir
abattu pour toujours
[Musique]
anéantie
frappé par un désastre et parra
[Musique]
au peuple ps le dieu des armes tu
abandonnes
[Musique]
voyez d'où ce qui reste de métro jeu
je fois
[Musique]
on
en
[Musique]
oh
j'ai déchiré mes vêtements j'ai mis mes
robes longues aux blaireaux plein et
notre défaite gémissez avec moi mais
l'on voit fut lait grillé avec moi
ah bon
i
à
[Musique]
oh
râpez rater votre poitrine effet vos
vêtements déchirés
et après trois angles
[Musique]
et
oh
à
ses beaux cheveux attachés et encore
athena
ça
à terre
[Musique]
oh
à l'heure soit l'écho du malaise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
la ville toute entière répond notre
désespoir
[Applaudissements]
adieu aux quartiers disparus
échangé aux blue du noyau de calais
nous essayerons de nos vies désolé et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]